I just want to point out because it's
all about man style today the boots I
love those and that's sort of it has
sort of an Elvis feel to it right well I
just feel more comfortable in Boots than
I do in dress shoes yeah
tell me about this tuxedo tonight uh
this is uh this is Gucci
Classic Hollywood this is your first
Golden Globe yes it is what does it feel
like being here tonight and what is what
does it mean to be here it's really
special it you know right now getting to
see all these people that I admire so
much and and under these circumstances I
just feel very happy and grateful I got
to tell you this Michelle Turner will
stab me if I do not let her talk if I
don't let you talk to her see look
where's your sister it's my sister's
around here somewhere where is your
sister yeah there she is come on up
there here she comes family Affairs get
on up here
we've been waiting to meet you yeah
listen I believe that I'm his auntie
okay so it's like I'll take that this is
my nephew I'm weirdly protective I was
like the first time we met in Memphis it
is yes we had this moment in Memphis
where we got to have amazing
conversations in the in the room where
all the records are on gracely so oh how
special I'm weirdly protective over him
how proud are you of this kid right here
I am so amazingly proud I can hardly
even express it in words I am I'm happy
that you are just as protective over him
as I am because I see him as a little 12
year old boy that I need to protect you
I mean we've got the family in here come
on up
hey Lisa how are you I just is
no no it's perfect what was it like
watching Austin on stage and during this
movie and the making of this movie it
was mind-blowing truly mind-blowing I
really didn't know what what to do with
myself after after I saw it yeah I had
to take like five days to process it
because it was so incredible and so spot
on
and so authentic
that yeah I I can't even describe
what it meant we we just celebrated your
dad's birthday a couple days ago so what
does it mean to you to be here tonight
you know in just a couple days after his
birthday celebrating him again in a way
that the masses are saying we see you I
you know I'm just so proud of it all
um
you know it's all flowing really nicely
together I'm gonna have the birthday
right now and you know I'm here to
support Austin and baz and film and I'm
so excited and I hope he wins you know
he deserves it we don't have to eat any
shoes
not yet we're waiting for that one
[Music]
foreign